Cain kills Abel Abel Cain's children
kill seven Kane's grandchildren kill
seventy fold and then tubal Cain pops up
on the horizon and he's the person who
makes artifices of war and so the story
in its fragmentary manner ties the
individual psychopathology that's
resentful and revenge seeking to the
proclivity for broad scale warfare and
this really hit me because I was
interested particularly in what was
happening in the Nazi camps with the
guards because the guards were
gratuitously cruel and I was very
curious about that and so here's an
interesting story this was in a book
called our ordinary Germans Hitler's
willing executioner's and it was a book
that was written about 30 years ago that
challenged the idea that the Nazi
phenomena was top-down order following
which I don't believe by the way I think
that's a very weak weak hypothesis
fascistic societies are fascistic at
every single level of organization
spiritually within the family within the
local community it's like a holograph
it's the same absolutely everywhere it's
not top-down I mean there are leaders
who get produced and maybe they catalyze
it but to blame it on the leaders is to
forget about the process by which the
leaders come to be so no you don't get a
pass that way so here's one of the
things that happened as the Nazis
started to lose the war so here's what
you should have done if you were a Nazi
and he wanted to win the war you should
have enslaved the Jews and the gypsies
and have them work right you have the
head should have had them work for the
benefit of the victory and then if you
wanted to liquidate them afterwards
that's the logical thing to do if you
want to win and we assume that Hitler
wanted to win but that's not a very
intelligent assumption why would you
assume that he wasn't exactly a good guy
so why should we assume that he was
aiming at the good that he was promoting
even in his own terms right
the glorious everlasting fourth Third
Reich right little rule for a thousand
years and be a bastion of civilization
in music because that's the sort of
thing he purported to be interested in
well so what do you do with the Jews and
the gypsies well round them up fine it
slave them fine
you don't kill them you certainly don't
devote a substantial proportion of your
war resources while you're losing to
accelerate the rate at which the
extermination is taking place because
that's a bit counterproductive unless
what you're aiming at is the maximum
possible mayhem in the shortest period
of time well so what happened as the
Germans started to lose the war did
Hitler lose faith in his own ability
no he believed that the Germans had
betrayed him with weakness and so he was
perfectly willing to accelerate the rate
at which Germany was losing the war and
so when Hitler and his minions have the
choice here's the choice you can suspend
your unnecessary demolition of people
win the damn war and then pick it up
afterwards or well you're losing you can
just accelerate the mayhem even though
it's counterproductive it's like what
they pick while they pick to accelerate
demand and so to me there's an old
psychoanalytic idea I think this was
derived by you you can't figure out what
someone is doing or why look at the
outcome and infer the motivation if it
produces mayhem perhaps it was aiming at
mayhem
now you know you have to use that dictum
carefully if someone's irritating you
you know maybe it's because you're
irritable head you should sort yourself
out but maybe it's because they're
actually aiming at irritating you and
that's the actual motivation so perhaps
not but it's another tool in your
analytical armament so and so you see
well this is the thing about warfare
that's so interesting about about
because you you can you can attribute it
to territoriality you can attribute it
to a war for resources that's what the I
would say wretchedly simple-minded
economists presume people fight over
scarce resources it's like hey we're a
little bit more sophisticated than that
and first of all what resources are you
talking about the bloody idiot had
nothing they live perfectly well what
did they have snow and seal blubber
you know people can live and
unbelievably deprived conditions and so
the idea that there are natural
resources that we fight over because
there's a shortage of them is a pretty
oversimplified
view of human beings it's like well why
do people fight well maybe they fight
sometimes for good reasons but very very
frequently they fight for bad reasons
and those bad reasons are our personal
as well as socio-cultural and economic
you know if you are a Nazi prison guard
for example whatever pathologies you
were carrying around in your destructive
little soul whatever element of Kane was
deeply embedded in you had the
opportunity to be manifest fully at
every moment of your waking existence
right you had these people who were
completely beholden to you with no
rights whatsoever to whom you could do
whatever your evil little heart
determined think well maybe that was a
motivation for putting them there to
begin with and all the cover story about
well we're trying to build the Third
Reich and we're trying to stabilize the
state and we're trying to do all these
good things maybe that's just a cover
story for the real motivation which is
nothing but but what the construction of
death camps that killed 6 million people
how about that and the obliteration of
120 million people on the planet and the
and the and the and the leaving of
Europe in runes maybe that was the
motivation or are we going to attribute
to Hitler the highest possible motives
say no it's an archetypal manifestation
of Kane now he's going to put up a front
it says well I'm your savior it's like
well destructive people think that kate
is their savior